comment comment les gens ils arrivent à
deux vides et que je suis pieds noirs
ça c'est un mystère que j'arrive pas à
les lucides et j'arrive pas j'y arrive
pas je n'arrive pas je sais bien qu'il
existe des clichés des légendes des
lieux combine contre lesquelles on peut
pas lutter c'est vrai on entend souvent
dire que les anglais sont gentleman que
les américains sont des grands enfants
que les écossais sont avares que les
allemands sont disciplinés que et 6 où
sont rusés etc etc et on dit aussi on
dit que les corses n'aime pas le travail
on le dit enfin je sais on le dit ah ben
moi jamais on m'a dit vous vous êtes
corse parce que moi le travail je peux
pas le voir
je ne peux pas le voir ces horreurs du
travail et pour hors du train j'ai passé
un jour j'aurai déjà ringard je vois le
moins creed rail gpr avait à y que j'ai
des boutons gg vraiment j'ai des
douleurs j'ai des douleurs j'aime pas
travail je sais pas si tout le monde il
est comme moi ça il ya trop de
responsabilités à le dire non non non
moi je prendrais pas cet engagement mais
moi personnellement pour ce qui me
concerne j'aime pas le travail moi mon
rêve
si qu'une place c'est une place par
exemple on va au bureau à 4h30 et on
s'en va à 16h45 le lin ji en se
souhaitant un bon week end
voilà voilà c'est ça walla walla
oisienne qu'on s'embrasse et puis les
vacances par un mois des vacances un
mois de vacances je suis à moi ce que
j'ai à moi c'est des comptes j'ai dans
mes vacances toute l'année on était la
plage en hiver la montagne de ski au
printemps la campagne et en automne on
se repose on recharge les accus voilà
c'est un voile harnois c'est je vois
voilà c'est ça que jamais le travail
j'aime pas chez patients moins jeunes
pourquoi je fais mon tir j'aime
eh bien je n'aime pas travailler jamais
on m'a dit vous êtes force à peine on me
voit je dis donc trois mouches par bart
comme ça on me dit oh la la
mais vous vous êtes pieds noirs comment
les gens ils arrivent à deviner ça je
comprends pas je comprends pas c'est un
mystère je comprends pas encore un belge
à 20 kg mais on arrive à le repérer un
baiser elle mon chéri les belges ils ont
un parent l'épouvantable les belges ils
ont un parent né à lewaï ans s'il vous
plaît vous voulez vous une fois ils ont
les boules et les fritons marie-andrée
s'il vous plaît venez vous s'il vous
plaît ça c'est belge tout craché il
manque juste normal qu'on puisse
vraiment mon chéri le manneken pis j'ai
vu à bruxelles
enfin je les ai vus il a fallu que je le
cherche parce que c'est pas les
pyramides
c'est ce qui vous unique est comme ça de
réelle juste auront eux disent que c'est
leur tour eiffel et bons amis ici comme
là dessus pour installer la télévision
avec les antennes la brève n'ont pas
encore la moitié d'une chaîne
enfin mme ebelle chez facile les
reconnaître mais moi comme les types il
arrive à reconnaître que je suis pieds
noirs ça c'est un mystérieux et vavoua
je comprends pas ce qu'on attend encore
et oui mais là encore jamais on m'a dit
vous vous êtes breton jamais ça je peux
le jurer pourtant 4 il ya pourtant il ya
des bretons qui sombra et benjamin on
l'a dit et en plus si tu es tu es si
c'est que ça je suis têtu moi j'ai la
tête mieux en émoi un mulliez moi j'ai
connu quand génie d'avoir avec moi via
assassiné son frère aîné pas la tête moi
j'ai la tête qu'on mène dans le maine au
travail afin dé et je me les crêpes
j'adore les crêpes au grand marnier au
sucre à la confiture et les biscuits
aussi les bretons et même des biscuits
les bretons ils aiment le biscuit ah oui
les bretons je vais lui les biscuits je
les lui les bretons et je les lui bon
fait pas sans moi j'aime les crèches ut
dessus j'aime les biscuits kenavo et
toute la smala et jamais on m'a dit vous
vous êtes breton jamais appel on me voit
magie où vous vous êtes pieds noirs
mais comme mon équipe ait encore un
chinois
ça se reconnaît facilement bien il ya un
truc qu'on peut reconnaître chinois tout
défaut ça se voit comme le nez au milieu
du visage c'est les pieds ils ont des
petits pieds et oui tandis que moi je
fais du caron profond ras cause du
football je jouais libéraux quand on est
descendu en 9e division défense et le
mans mais enfin et puis il ya autre
chose il ya autre chose encore plus
rencontre on peut reconnaître un chinois
vraiment à tous les coups c'est qu'ils
sont fort au ping pong
ils sont champions du monde ont marqué
déjà pour manger dans des baguettes
alors de tout petits sont entraînés
la glace alors dans mon monde prenne pas
pour un chinois à la rigueur je l'admets
mais comment les types il faut pour
deviner que je suis pieds noirs ça c'est
un mystère mais la meilleure c'est quand
tout à l'heure pour venir je prends un
taxi je prends un taxi
j'étais en train de discuter avec le
chauffeur là j'étais justement en train
de lui dire que le compteur il allait
très vite et pourtant la voiture elle
aller doucement
et alors oui alors je lui faisais
remarquer sur coup là alors ils me
disent mais vous vous n'est ce pas de là
bas jeudi 12 de finlande parce que je le
voyais venir lui 1 je croyais à venir
l'arnaqueuse voit et me dit non non non
non je voulais dire vous n'êtes pas de
vous êtes à pied noir jo je dis oui mais
comment vous m'avez reconnu ils me
diront qu'on manque en revanche quand on
vous entend parler alors un il suffit je
l'aï patin couffin
c'est pas vrai [ __ ] relâche deviennent
dingues deviennent d'intesa me dire
quand on entend quand on pense à quai
samedi à tampa
alors admettons alors dans ces
conditions comment ça se fait à alger
pendant trente ans que j'habite et bab
el oued
quand je parlais et je parle jamais un
chip il m'a dit une seule fois au vous
vous êtes pieds noirs
j'aime ça c'est lui qu'on mode saas et
une étoile